alors au jardin botanique de la Réunion
on propose aujourd'hui de la grimpe dans
les arbres donc cette nouvelle activité
à Lille suite à une formation que notre
association a
lancé sur l'île de la Réunion en lien
avec une association d'arboristes
grimpeurs et la guerre qui s'appelle le
caoi le comité d'Arbor de l'océan Indien
et donc du coup on est en train de
former donc des Réunionnais à cette
nouvelle activité de grandeur donc la
grimpe d'arbres est une activité
qui mêle à la fois l'environnement la
connaissance de la nature le respect de
l'art et le sport l'animation et aussi
le social puisque en fait on s'adresse
vraiment à tous les publics les jeunes
comme les personnages et aussi ça nous
arrive de faire grimper des des
personnes de plus de 80 ans
des personnes en situation d'obésité ou
des personnes en situation de handicap
on a des ateliers donc qui sont là qui
s'adapte vraiment à
toi c'est un petit peu la particularité
de la grande table c'est un petit peu
aussi son itinéraire le fait qu'on
puisse installer le matin des cordes
dans un arbre et puis le soir on les
désinstalle et c'est comme si en fait on
n'était jamais passé là le tout étant de
trouver en fait des arbres qui
s'adaptent bien justement à cette grimpe
et ça il y en a beaucoup à la Réunion
donc ça tombe très bien
et après ça dépend
ça va
de nathanier de la zone dans lequel vous
le ramassez voilà
ce sont toujours ou presque toujours des
graines de palmier ou de cocotiers le
plus connu dans la zone étant le
coco-fesse des Seychelles par exemple
qui est une graine de cocotier et ici à
la réunion nous avons la graine de la
tanière rouge palier donc endémique de
la Réunion qui donne de l'ivoire végétal
voilà on la connaît bien parce qu'on la
mange volontiers mais si on la laisse
sécher qu'on la travaille on aura le
plaisir de découvrir un bijou et à peu
près 5 ans qu'on travaille sur tous les
ivoirs végétaux et sur la graine de la
tanière rouge ça fait un peu plus de
deux ans on travaille vraiment
d'arrache-pied pour pour révéler en fait
l'excellence de la matière parce que la
matière est renferme cette valeur là